the worst thing about my kids catching
us having sex is that we were having sex
in positions
that you couldn't play off you know
there's some sexual positions
that you could play off there's a lot of
couples here tonight i see you with your
ladies sir
viewing your lady having sex and your
lady laying on the side of your kids
come busting the room you can play that
off
all you got to do is sit up act like
you're watching tv hey hey
hey [ __ ] out of here don't come back in
here to be done watching tv
if you real good and you got your bottom
half covered up
when you sit up you can technically keep
[ __ ] while you talking hey
hey hey get get your ass out the goddamn
room
don't come in the goddamn room
your lady be trying to talk come in here
this is my favorite part of this show
but then because he's a male feminist he
decides that he's gonna go
on time now ladies in the audience
who will be underneath the man in the 69
position
will feel my pain in this moment because
as he climbed on top
like a koala i got into this position oh
this is where i die
like right like we are no longer in
control men you are using our throat
like a vagina and we can't breathe
so underneath this guy right and guys
like you got a beautiful view right you
get a beautiful [ __ ] like no
like just like a beautiful flower like a
beautiful [ __ ] right
what a weekend
deep balls [ __ ] the trifecta
[Applause]
our only our only saving grace is that
little bit of skin between the balls and
the [ __ ]
that little grit and you just look off
into it like a vast ocean
hoping that everything is going to be
okay
whenever whenever i'm in this position i
always think of that scene from the lion
king you know
where simba is talking to buffalo and
he's like father
what is
[Laughter]
how many guys in here honestly have used
a dental dam before
do you know what a dental dam is you do
no one's ever used one before huh
see see what i'm saying you see what i'm
saying about the condoms y'all just like
put that condom on
but you know the dental dam is it's a
piece of a trash bag right
about as big as a napkin that you flip
out and you lay it over a woman's vagina
just in case you know it's it's it's
poison
to protect us from imminent danger
but we don't use it because you'll be
insulted
if i'm getting ready to have sex with
you and i'll pull out a piece of a trash
man
and you go uh what is that oh i'm just
gonna lay that over here vagina
just in case it kills me i'm sorry what
did you say and we see that
face like nothing forget it don't even
pretend i don't see that i'd rather die
than to insult my way out of some i'd
rather just get what you got
never i never get laid a couple weeks
ago finally that we had sex because it
was my birthday and she's like go ahead
so all right fine
i do not need her to be into it i just
want to get [ __ ] annually laid that's
all i don't give a [ __ ]
and it's always that's the fight i don't
feel like it you don't have to [ __ ]
feel like it i don't give a [ __ ]
and then we get into it now she feels
like it now she's invested in it now i'm
working for her again
somehow it's no longer this [ __ ] for me
it's like about her
and that's great look i love her so i
always try like the last time i was
trying not to come really hard because i
like her [ __ ] it i want to give her a
shot at it you know so
i'm trying
trying not to come very hard very hard
when you're ready to come and you want
to not come because of your woman that
is really hard
i don't know if women really appreciate
what goes into that [ __ ]
the kind of stuff you gotta think about
the thoughts you have to have because
the force you're fighting is the
universe
it's life on earth trying to march
forward
and you're trying to stop that [ __ ] for
her
your body doesn't give a [ __ ] you tell
your body hey hold up don't come your
body's like [ __ ] you what are you
talking about
this is bigger than all of us here
and the only way to push that off is to
have terrible images
in here like weird sick [ __ ] up things
in your head
you need them it's the only way she's
having a great time she's just off
thinking about flowers and puppies i
don't know
and the guy's thinking about like dog
[ __ ] smeared on a dead guy or something
like that
in order to maintain her happiness
she's like passion and ecstasy and he's
like liza minnelli and richard nixon
having a diarrhea fight something i
don't know
and as women you get older you get
hornier which just [ __ ] up
just insatiable want to [ __ ] all that
goddamn time
remember when you're 20 you couldn't
handle dick you always had excuses
i feel too horrible in this position
dude women in their 30s and 40s take
dick like a boxer working on his ass
we're gonna check in on him baby keep
[ __ ]
[Music]
just wanted all the goddamn time
you'll have sex with a few minutes later
come on let's go again
right we just did it
why do we have to do it again if we just
did it
why but i didn't come
if i fail a test i don't take the test
right over
that's how you fail a test twice
clearly i have to do some studying some
preparation
to pass this test
not to mention you don't want 35 year
old
second nut dick
35 year old second nut dick
looks like the [ __ ] outside the car
dealership
[Applause]
you better have some good [ __ ] timing
ladies
because you need a time insertion on
full extension
if it's even a little bit bent it's
folding it out
and i'm stuffing it in anyway i don't
give a [ __ ] you wanted this
uh female question about anal this is
the last one i got a kid
i got to get out of here um my husband
keeps jokingly bringing up the subject
of anal sex
it'd be funny if i [ __ ] you in the
[Laughter]
did ass have him call write me in and
ask how we should go about asking you
for anal
oh there's no there's no asking with
anal you just do it
wow i'm kidding wow now what it is
you have to you have to do a survey
during during doggy style
that's what that's how you figure it out
it's done with the thumb
it's sort of a rubbing circular motion
williams
[Laughter]
what is wrong with you just finish
reading it
just finish reading it okay just stop
and just read
please for the love of god oh this guy
just joking around
i i love these pancakes so much that i'd
love to [ __ ] you in the ass just kidding
just cuz it's kidding sweetheart
oh this poor guy he wants to [ __ ] you in
the ass he doesn't know how to bring it
up after cornflakes this is the funniest
thing ever
in the past he always acted as though he
thinks it's gross
maybe he didn't he's just watched so
much porn that he's now graduated to it
which is the danger my sister told me
that a few of her girlfriends said they
actually
enjoy it oh that means your sister likes
it
you know i have this friend yeah she
loves it
says that it enhances he's very well
endowed
and i weigh only all of 95 pounds yeah
it ain't happening
it ain't happening i think my concern is
well founded yes it is
but wait a minute those porno girls can
take it you can take it too come on be a
trooper uh what is your opinion about it
should i let him
what would nia say you just heard what
he what she has to say
he he listens he listens to this say
no please you want female listeners punk
help me out thanks [ __ ] yourself uh
if you really don't want to do it then
you should do it
you know there's no reason it'd be one
thing if you didn't have a viable option
somewhere else
yeah that was actually you know what i
mean it's basically
you have a nike's you have a nice
probably mid-sized
uh sedan going on there and this guy for
some reason
despite his size is going with the mini
cooper
look they do i got to be honest
workshops it's not something you don't
you don't want to do that with your wife
you just don't
okay i thought that's the one person you
would want to do no not about
dingbat that said she's already banging
you at work okay that's who you do it
too right on the desk
you [ __ ] in the ass mush your face
into the card catalog
and then you know what the card catalog
whatever the [ __ ] they got nowadays
that that's who you deal with that's it
[Music]
you